elle est passée comme tant d'autres et
c'est vrai que c'est arrêter le sud yves
hocher c'est c'est déjà une occasion
peut-être de la faire savoir que nous
avons des des produits d'exception et
c'est moi je le fais goûter la chine le
tibet est bon et je crois même qu'elles
appréciaient alors je pense que c'est
important
des fois quand avant de critiquer de
savoir qui je suis moi je suis d'abord
le chef et qui a qui a fait de la
garanderie lente et les caisses
caribéenne sa lettre de noblesse
quand je pense que moi j'ai pas de je
suis pas là pour wendy qui est qui moi
je suis là pour faire promouvoir que
nous avons un produit et que notre
produit de pointe n'a pas de complexe
si les martiniquais pense que le fait de
partager avec une intelligence humaine
tels que quelle que soit la personne
aujourd'hui des symboles période et bien
qu'il me pousse à vous avez mangé moins
jeunes à dieu moi ça fait longtemps que
je n'ai plus la chaîne didonne enquête
ninon mes pieds je ne sais pas si on en
veut je pense que quand on explose dans
un salon en explosion s'exposent à
recevoir tout le monde moi non
préoccupation c'est de mettre en avant
et en avant de tout et presse
métropolitaine nationale le produit que
nous présentons c'est à dire 12 légumes
de l'agriculture martiniquaise qui
représente quand même deux mille
exploitants de la martinique c'est ça
qui est important
moi je ne fais pas de politique moi je
suis un acteur économique
madame le pen s'est attaché à regarder
nos produits comme monsieur hamon s'est
attaché à regarder nos produits comme
beaucoup d'hommes politiques et beaucoup
de maux économiques et ou qui sont les
bienvenus dont près de notre agriculture
martiniquaise
vous pensez que cette histoire va avoir
des répercussions sur sur votre
entreprise
je pense que la conscience globale de
notre économie passera au dessus de
cette petite polémique